une paupérisation générale des pays
occidentaux et à les électeurs de trump
ya les gens qui ont fait le break site
en angleterre est allé gilet jaune en
france ces conditions qu'il faut
absolument redistribuer plus
correctement les salaires ont
effectivement stagné c'est pas du tout
un mythe il ya vraiment une baisse des
conditions et il faudrait distribuer et
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on est en train
de vivre aujourd'hui est ce que vraiment
l'état et surtout les états unis où jay
sept sont en train de devenir maîtres
comme vous dites de la situation et ben
moi je crains que la réalité soit que
corporate america soit aujourd'hui
devenu tellement puissant que n'importe
quel président élu doit négocier avec
eux pour des arrangements qui leur
conviennent que eux ont souhaité parce
que si on se revient sur l'historique de
comment l'union européenne a voulu taxer
les gaffes et a été menacé plusieurs
fois de représailles
et finalement c'est la france tout seul
qui a fait sa taxe gafa et le retard que
c'est un prix et la haye les menaces de
représailles contre les sectes
automobiles allemands irlandais et
autres que les états-unis ont fait
aujourd'hui on est juste en train
d'essayer de mettre fin à cette guerre
économique et de trouver un arrangement
que corporate america avons la
légitimité du g7 on peut pas dire
qu'elle soit vraiment solide
parce qu'effectivement et encore la
chine ya la russie a le brésil mais
surtout les petits pays qui doivent
suivre
est-ce que les fortunes physiques ont
été concernés par ce 15% ce 15% et très
bien parce qu'il faut s'attaquer aux
multinationales ça s'est envolé à part
je veux bien mais ben laden avait aussi
promis d'augmenter à 40 % l'impôt sur
ceux qui gagnent plus de 400 millions $
aux états-unis
et ça ça a été abandonnée pour
information donc les fortunes physique
continueront l'échappée alors que c'est
elle qui rassemble en fait les fortunes
les plus vastes dans des structures
comme les trusts les trois options
internationaux mais surtout les petits
pays comme la suisse ou l'irlande ou le
luxembourg est en fait ils n'ont pas
voix au chapitre c'est à dire qu'ils se
voient appliquer des choses qui a été
d'abord décidé au sein du g7
ensuite du g20 ensuite de l' ocde
ensuite des réunions de banques
centrales ensuite de toutes les grandes
puissances qui vont s'ajouter
mais eux vont finir en bout de chaîne
par juste appliqué des choses mais bon
renonce
alors souveraineté fiscale
[Musique]